I like it let's do it okay unhelpful
advice with Bobby
kalila and Tom Segura like it I'm in my
late 20s and have never had a girlfriend
meeting women seems like an impossible
task to me I tried online dating but I
felt like I never stood out to any girls
I was attracted to despite being
slightly above average looking in real
life I have no idea what to do I was
very depressed a very depressed isolated
teenager so I kind of missed out on
normal relationship stuff
now I'm getting near 30 and kind of feel
unfuckable
with my crappy job and lack of social
prowess I've had sex only had sex once
it was in a with an escort I felt bad
about it and never did it again how do I
get a girlfriend thanks max that's
[ __ ] heavy max last week's was even
heavier than that yeah we had a
fourteen-year-old gay kid from Saudi
Arabia who was in love but he might have
decapitated if it ever got out yeah he
didn't know what to do oh I hope you
yeah no I'm swinging for it now with
this kid um max is always wet but it's
about 30 almost 30
max I mean max I feel like you're my
type of guy and I'm not I'm not being
I'm not
I really do truly believe that I believe
that we're of the same make make up my
whole life I always thought I'm never
gonna get laid girls don't like me I'd
go to no I'd ask a girl out they'd say
no I mean it was just like I would try
to get girls drunk I'd get everything in
the book I couldn't get anything going
okay and then me and my friends in my
early 20s we came up with a thing and a
philosophy or idea called the launching
pad and the launching pad is this is you
go out and you [ __ ] no matter how you
either escorts I know you feel bad about
it but that's I think the right path to
just [ __ ] the [ __ ] ton of hookers [ __ ]
hookers you know me just you know [ __ ]
girls that are way below
you know me yeah yeah yeah and just just
get in the routine of [ __ ] because I
think what it
is is that when you don't have a lot of
just listen to me listen I think ever I
have the right idea
well you don't when you sit there and go
I'm not getting any [ __ ] I can't get
any [ __ ] yeah it's basically your now
this group this idea of a woman and sex
and all that stuff is so large that it
is overwhelming but if you have it and
you realize that it's just sex it
doesn't mean you know I mean we don't
you know you [ __ ] a girl and you're like
wow I was weird essentially you're
basically saying you got to figure out a
way to get some confidence yeah really
what you're saying so it's like do it
slow instead of shooting for the stars
yeah that woman is not attractive enough
for me just if a woman shows any
interest if you're getting any
reciprocation what's the way yeah just
take it for a ride man like Allen
Iverson says it's just practice it's all
about practice right yeah will you wear
a condom because you don't want to
impregnate practice yeah no you get a
baby from a prac and also dude you're
probably and everyone like a lot of guys
are guilty of this you know probably
just trying way too hard you're putting
too much thought into it that's I know
it sounds like I know you but you just
seem to take like just look man you need
to [ __ ] be yourself and whatever
comes your way
like Bobby said take a swing at it you
know be don't be a [ __ ] derelict Pig
about it but just be like be decent and
and just you need a built you need to
get some like rotations in there yeah
yeah I knew a guy named Barry and Barret
and Barry was a guy when I was a kid you
know I went to rehabs and Barry was this
yeah uh two three rehabs but there was
this guy who he was um Irish and he look
like a hobbit he's just this round sixty
year old man with like orange a white
hair and he was always dreads
gleaming face look Santa and he was just
so happy all the time and I got to know
Barry and at the 8th at that age he was
a virgin is that just you know I'm not
gay I just you know they just don't like
me
yeah but he's like my check it out he
goes I've completely
he completely let it go he's accepted if
this is God's will then so be it but
that's not the world for max I'm done I
know and then I moved to LA and I went
back to San Diego and Barry is married
with a beautiful like 50 roll check
mm-hmm
and I'm like any xyq hey it happened and
I'm like how you guys I don't know I
just did yeah well my point though is is
that there's no timeframe on it yeah you
gotta exude that I don't give a [ __ ]
good more than you exude that
desperation like when you go out with
girls don't clean out your eyes like the
way Bobby did you just leave the crust
all up in there mmm you know like leave
your car looking like a [ __ ] you know
hoarders car put a pile of shoes in your
living room max yeah just be your
absolute self is yourself there who's
just as you know if you think you're
awful there's somebody there who's
equally as awful who's gonna find you
attractive yeah
yeah I just don't I feel bad I mean I
wish max I was your friend so I could
just see your dated your day-to-day
interactions with people and maybe I
gave to give you hints I also have a
perfect example of we have a friend
who's insanely good-looking an insanely
good-looking guy but he has the max
syndrome he just cannot open cannot
close he's gay is a good job
please I fashion L soccer Wolverine yeah
not using his claws and he's always like
girls oh okay yeah he just no just does
not I've seen him in parties yeah
doesn't know today he's such a good like
just wholesome dude that it almost I
think that girls don't get that feeling
of wanting to like sexualized a minute
oh yeah he's a good boy you know yeah
cuz there's something still dangerous
about you Tom me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there is a danger about you that I
think every guy needs you luckily I
think you know your Steve Byrne right
yeah is a nice guy yeah but there's
still something his wife knows that
there's a little danger in them right so
there's still that little thing of like
you know mystery
yeah some mystery right you need that
you can't be a sucker
[Music]